[Musique]
bienvenue au sans filtre le podcast on
parle aussi avec nos invités date site
super chanteur et moi de dôme plantes
cette semaine le sans filtre et présenté
par terry un terrien bureaux de
comptables d'hommes j'imagine que tout
serait pas faire de la comptabilité
non j'aime ça c'est une des choses que
je déteste le plus moi aussi terrain
terriens ça fait 25 ans qui sont ouverts
ils sont spécialisés en pme y offre un
service clé en main donc ce soit pour la
tenue de livres
leur rapport d'impôt les états
financiers vous allez voir ils font tout
ça pour vous deux personnes qui se
lancent vraiment en affaires pour faire
la comptabilité je pense fait que si
vous faites affaire avec justement
terrain terrain vous allez pouvoir vous
vous mettre votre attention dans des
choses qui comptent vraiment votre
business
au contraire des grandes firmes terrain
terrien fera contact humain avec avec
les les entrepreneurs qui est avec une
expertise en fait dans le domaine dans
les domaines d'avenir fait que si vous
avez une entreprise qui ya des nouvelles
idées quitte innovatrice terriens
terriens on est capable de faire le
meilleur pour vous en faites
et si vous utilisez le code en fait si
vous mentionnez sans filtre quand vous
allez voir pour prendre votre premier
rendez vous vous sauver 50 % sur votre
première année financière ce qui est
énorme c'est des frais que vous aurez
pas payer vous allez pouvoir investir
dans autre chose c'est surtout du temps
que vous allez sauver énormément pour
être sûrs que c'est fait
professionnellement de terrain terriens
mentionné sans filtre on est content de
s'associer avec jean cocteau rien de
rien il ya il encourra le plein de
podcasts en fait c'est vraiment impliqué
là dedans c'est tout à leur honneur même
c'est tout en leur honneur puis si vous
voulez les encourager que vous avez
vous-même d'entreprise honnêtement
fait affaire avec eux sur ce travail on
s'en fout lorsque j'ai dit celui-ci
quitte une autre icône et curieuse
militante féministe alors son plus
récent livre s'intitule on peut plus
rien dire
les militantismes à l'ère des réseaux
sociaux un livre qui traite des sceaux
charles justin warriors c'est militants
des réseaux sociaux qui est critique qui
dérange et qui sont souvent caricaturée
alors le livre est d'expliquer la
conversation qu'on va avoir une liste
expliqué pourquoi sont souvent mal perçu
un peu psychologue la médication
piscicole heures méthode est aussi c'est
quoi les critiques légitimes qu'on peut
faire à certains d'entre eux donc ceux
qui sont toutes en nuances parce qu'on
eut certes un bain souvent d'accord
parfois des accords tout est dans la
nuance est dans le vivre ensemble
alors j'espère qu'ils avaient aimé ça
j'espère que ça vous faire un petit
plouf léché ou juste potro ouais une
présentation elle très intéressante
justicier personnes qui méritent
d'être écouté sinon vous nous écoutez
présentement soit sur youtube ou sur
l'application balade aux sources pas les
frais peu importe la plateforme sur
laquelle vous écoutez ce que ce soit au
dc auditif ou visuel
abonnez-vous à notre chaîne laissez-nous
des commentaires si vous écoutez en
audio laissez-nous un rating de cinq
étoiles ça fait son bout de chemin ça
permet à plus de monde d'écouter le
podcast d'entendre parler du sans filtre
on a une page pétri en aussi où est-ce
qu'on a du contenu exclusif
ou est ce qu on envoie les podcasts en
avance donc qui sait aussi une
excellente façon nous encourage et
surtout une excellente façon nous
encourager à continuer ce projet là et
sans plus attendre
après une intro déjà trop long bon
podcast verdict
[Musique]
c'est commencer officiellement comme ça
merci beaucoup d'être c'est un plaisir
dont tu étais tu étais dans cette liste
de personnes à éviter parce que on aime
traiter des enjeux sociaux sociaux ici
puis on ne le fait pas assez souvent
ouf là on avait on avait l'occasion de
la foire l'habitude de parler d' espaces
de non pas exclusivement de sport non à
se parler vraiment n'importe quoi mais
je crois que moins que moi
personnellement ça me touche de par ma
blonde qui est activiste pour maxi vis
pour plusieurs causes
je suis moi comme mégane cc puis -
vocale par exemple considère ces
activistes j'avais justement cette
discussion le avec ma blonde
dernièrement parce que je me disais
qu'est ce qu'un activiste
mais je pense que des décotes prononce
en faveur d'une cause sociale pipi dans
le domaine vie guen je les observe le
dect dictée véhicule s'est dit quelque
chose qui confronte les gens mais je les
vis si ggb j'ai fait le défi 21 jours il
est juste de dire aux gens que je
faisais le défi 20,21 jour il se braquer
is matt
donc d'après moi est une activité
considérée comme un militant vegan par
plusieurs personnes ce site définitif
par contre admettons que j'aime
admettons je compare mon implication
avec celle de beaucoup de beaucoup
d'activistes du milieu surtout pour les
droits le droit des animaux ce qui est
moins - mon mon cheval de bataille par
rapport aux organismes j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya plusieurs niveaux mais il ya
plusieurs sortes de militants puis à
plusieurs pis j'ai un collègue fabrice
belle kim qui me fait peur de
classification des militants tandis
qu'ils sont plus
et puis il y avait il y avait des titres
et l'inde j'oublie le nommer est plus
lent en a qui sont plus des cheerleaders
tandis qu'ils sont plus des éducateurs
tandis qu'ils sont plus revendicateurs
ton ex en plus des films ou des stores
âgées comme moi
[Rires]
je sais pas s'il fera entrer dans la
catégorie cheerleader métier tête un
enthousiaste du mécanisme pete est un
éducateur parce que tu tu fais partager
des trucs des recettes puis ça permet
aux gens d'adhérer à ce mode de vie la
dignité sans être legault avec les
pancartes dans les manifestations c'est
moi j'ai jamais fait j'ai déjà participé
des manifestations mais c'est vraiment
pas une environnement dans lequel je me
sens à l'aise
donc si notre définition de militants
c'est quelqu'un qui bosse dans des
manifestations avec des pancartes
faudrait au minimum et emilie taille est
quand même quelque chose qui sonne la
demande mais les deux corps de milice de
combat des quelque chose type tandis qu'
il ya beaucoup de vegan aussi que cela
parle peu il t'en parle ils veulent pas
en parler puis la seule raison pour que
des voix parce qu'il composa questions
qui ont paul goude engagé dans une
argumentation woods est convaincu ce que
je disais que je faisais mon défi 21
jours les jeunes c'est justifié je pense
que le véganisme en particulier le ccc
perçu par les gens comme eux c'est comme
s'ils vous placer sur une autorité
morale qui fait qu'ils se sentent juger
ça que ça génère tout de suite même 5000
comptait pas dans le prosélytisme pas
dépasser en train d'essayer de
convaincre les gens les gens sentent que
tu as fait la morale un peu c'est une
espèce d'hypersensibilité que les gens
ont que j'observe par rapport aux côtés
ce qui est spécial c'est que les
quinquas sûr c'est que me levais gagnent
en parle tout le temps tout le monde
vivait comme tout le monde mais moi tu
comme l'expérience de ce que j'observe
autour de moi c'est parce que justement
ces temps par le post se poser la
question
ils le savent bien des beaux parce que
depuis le pour coter viganais l'anapi
mois
ça devient comme une argumentation
malgré toi ouais je vous en parle à
personne à utiliser le mot caricature
parce que par mon livre on peut plus
réduire les militants à l'ère des
réseaux sociaux français que j'essaie de
faire de montrer que souvent d'une
perception des militants quittent
extremis qui est vraiment on les
comprend poppy souvent il comprend pas
parce que leurs positions sont
caricaturés parce qu'on est susceptible
parce que les médias caricature ses
positions là parce que l'immédiat
comment ils ont fait des clips de cinq
secondes tandis que pas beaucoup
d'espacé pour élaborer ta pensée donc je
voulait rétablir un peu l'effet monza
mais attendez quand vous quand vous
sauter au plafond parce que vous pensez
que québec solidaire veut imposer le mot
matrimoine à tout le monde mais prenez
le temps d'analyser comment ça c'est
sorti dans les médias pourquoi on a
cette impression là alors que tout ce
qu'ils veulent c'est dire mais on lui
dit patrimoine dans nos documents à nous
qui sommes un parti féministe on va
utiliser le mot héritage cultive c'est
vraiment plus nuancé que 16 ans qu'est
ce qui s'est passé vraiment exactement
dans l'instant aujourd'hui c'est un peu
plus attention au fait où est
l'objectivité adam fisch poche et c'est
ce qu'il faudrait c'est de ramener d'un
côté ou de l'autre peu importe si c'est
quoi c'est quoi la vraie chose qui s'est
passé ce coup là c'est quoi et je pense
qu'on aime se sont indignés on lui
reproche souvent à nous les militants de
nous unit facilement mais je pense que
le grand public devant ces
manifestations le ces critiques le m
ça crée un cercle qui est qui et qui est
malsain d'un point de vue de la société
parce que c'est ça ça sectionne ça
creuse encore plus le la tranchée ancli
en cliquant des millions d'humains puis
on n'arrête pas de dire que les opinions
sont de plus en plus paul arrivé on se
chambre haye qu on se comprend pas on se
comprend pas mais est ce qu'on cherche
vraiment comprendre à conforter nos vies
a pas vouloir écouter les idées des
autres
un rien de plus facile pourrait valider
une idée que de la caricature où la
dépouille quelque chose de niese
pierrick étonnant que je l'aimerais sent
que c'est aussi commun que la société
construite auto sur internet et au ton
ton l'iton terrain de bataille c'est les
réseaux sociaux pis j'ai l'impression
que c'est un environnement qui encourage
pas la nuance qui encourage peau la
discussion
stone assistait ce sans courage les
clics les cliques bête sans courage
daily deals plus radicale puisque si ces
autres qui sont plus des réactions ça
carbure aux réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux par fax et six mois kim qui me
dérange l'impression que les réseaux
sociaux créés de leur nature une
polarisation kike plus grande qu'ils
quittent rarement qu'avait avancé
absolument piriou on commence à pouvoir
démontrer sa avec des études puis
effectivement telle indignation et je
tenterai de dire les mots de jeff y ait
dans le documentaire indignation de
commencer mais j'ai regardé ça les
choses il y 10 et scellait le carburant
des réseaux sociaux c'est qui et c'est
vrai je pense qu'on est en période
d'apprentissage c'est quand on y pense
facebook ça fait une dizaine d'années
que c'est dans nos vies
fillon qui l'a d'abyane au parent qui
sont arrivés là dessus une coupe des
knicks est membre qui sont pas toujours
habile avec les réseaux sociaux mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'on apprenne à se
parler
déjà il ya des gens qui réalisent pas
que j'imagine que tu l'as vécu un jour
au lendemain une personnalité publique
il ya des gens qui réalisent pas qu'en
disant quelque chose à une personnalité
publique
c'est lui le leader soit ça peut être
très violente
quand tu dis ça vient donner son
chandail a pas d'alluré à l'air d'avoir
les cheveux cruel de voix donc c'est pas
quelque chose que tu dirais pas ça fasse
mais c'est quelque chose qu'on se permet
de dire sur les réseaux sociaux parce qu
on al impression qu un écrin qui nous
qui crée une distance 6 donc faut qu'on
apprenne à ne plus considérer cette
détention mais à voir qu'on ait une
discussion comme on aurait dans un salon
web puis j'ai l'impression que au québec
ce cet effet là
et grands parce que notre notre la
population et malgré tout reste
tranquille parce que elle maintenant des
taux aux etats unis c'est écrit quelque
chose contre ça c'était quelque chose à
brad pitt sur sa page personnelle il y
avait reconnu sans savoir si m
mais oui j'ai une amie qui s'est fait
bloquer par madonna
c'est drôle parce que je me disais pipi
et madonna pour de vrai gère très mal sa
passe à regarder sa page instagram on
dirait que tout flou c'est pas à baisser
comme au sahara salariés à la grandeur
du personnel est bloqué
et oui c'est tuer quelqu'un avec une
grosse visibilité ou tribune g et c'est
connu que marc madiot ne pas séjourner à
bloquer mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
c'est si je trouve
signe de ce département podcast mois
lorsque une des raisons qui motivent si
c'est parce que on se parle pas on se
parle rarement face à face le seuil de
moins en moins de moyens conversation
verbale qui tire une heure et demie deux
heures on va jaser on reprend le mans
est d'accord cependant pas d'accord sur
d'autres faits aussi mais on va sortir
de l'eau on est des autres papiers amis
puis on a limité les prix bas de gamme
comprend s'excuser mais mais c'est ça la
fat et puis on y on est de moins en
moins d'accord en désaccord j'ai
l'impression il ya ce puits ou si les
gens sont toujours plus nuancée qui en
on laisse les réseaux sociaux ce qui
sait quelque chose comme dit souvent
qu'en montant personnes en mon dieu tu
es bien plus relax que ce que je pensais
mais c'est sûr que c'est sûr que si on
maîtrise pas totalement non plus l'image
qu'on projette de noël sur les réseaux
sociaux puis les gens se font une image
caricaturale de nous à partir de joseph
pas toujours en train d'exprimer mes
pensées sur les réseaux sociaux quand je
vois une belle fleur sur le thé je vois
pas je pourrai le faire mais je ne suis
pas dans l'espace pour mon réflexe qui
j'ai d'autres choses à offrir ou acté
c'est sûr que ce que les gens
connaissent deux mois c'est bien plus la
fille qui a des opinions féminin qui qui
critiquent des choses que souvent
n'avait pas vu donc on avait
l'impression que c'était pas vraiment un
problème qui qui qui fait chier les gens
parce qu'ils pensent que son corps ait
finalement bay ont peut-être à y avait
peut-être pas vu ça de cette façon là
que c'est peut-être une autre forme de
sexe avoir nommé deux mois ap je pense
que souvent ça c'est les gens aiment ce
adhéré à l'idée qu'ils sont une bonne
personne qui dans la vie en général on
est des bonnes personnes
c'est ma vie c'est pas une bombe ou des
méchants mais quand tu soulignes des
fois des injustices bay rapidement comme
on est susceptible on est très fragile
pour dans les prisons de camp des
injustices on s'unit on est coupable de
ces injustices lehoux est une bonne
personne ne pas les avoir vu une vision
un peu simpliste la vie mais moi je
pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse critiquer
des choses puis 5-5
les gens aient toujours à le prendre
personnel comme les arnaques pétrole
surtout qu'on ait jamais seul
responsable des injustices ou d'aider
ces systèmes qui qui qui se met en place
de façon un peu subtile ainsi si l'on
table si c'est de construire puis on est
tous en plus victimes un peu coupable de
s'épiler raciste un bon exemple les gens
quand on dit que quelque chose de
raciste mais ils ont une conception du
raciste c'est comme soit et être l'heure
où des portions à sociétés is a une
vision hyper votre épaule esclavage
oui non oui ces gens riches chinois vous
savez qu est ce que je dis
entre ceux entre hitler et j'peux
racistes comme pas un moyen de dire
betis a peut-être manqué de sensibilité
ou seules images que ça renvoie c'est
peut-être pas positif pour les
communautés racisées août et puis tout
ça rentre dans un gros paquet d'affaires
qu'on nomme le racisme système et qui
comme tu disais ça existe depuis des
années qui personne est coupable
personnellement de ce à moins que il ya
eu un gros soulèvement populaire contre
la commission sur le raciste pitt et les
gens disaient je veux pas qu'on fasse le
projet le procès des québécois pinault
n'a alors que qu'est ce qu'il ya de mal
à faire preuve un exercice
d'introspection
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que ça peut nous
coûter est ce qu'on est vraiment très
que le puck qui peuvent quoi la perte
peut arriver que d'observer les raisons
de certaines inégalités et si j'ose dire
mais sans que si tu te poses un seul
titre montech baisse parce que les gens
confondent le mot systémique
systématique ou s'il complète
complètement refusé mon hypothèque
systématiquement dénoncé samedi les
québécois sont plus racistes que les
hôtes ont dit non mais si je pense quand
on parlera systémique on dit pas que les
québécois sont plus racistes que les
autres audi pop mais est ce que tu peux
vraiment affirmer qu'il n'ya pas de
racisme au collège aucun pack c'est le
mieux qui vous arrivera une commission
comme ça c'est qu'on verrait qu'il ya un
peu grasse et systémique payent pour
arriver c'est qu'on se rend compte que
beaucoup de la systémique car et il vaut
mieux savoir pile savoir comment triste
oui il ya un problème il faut le
regarder en face et comme tout pcc des
mots c'est des mots qui font peur c'est
lyrisme se faire accuser de n'importe
quel ça ça vient de chez qui
profondément ti moi j'avais j'avais une
conversation avec ma blonde autrefois
puis sur un comportement quelque chose
que j'avais 10 ou une de mes opinions
qu'ils étaient
qui était sexy puis moi me considère pas
du tout comme sexistes me faire dire ce
comportement là et sexiste ça m'a quand
même dit fait ouais non mais non non non
finalement c'est on s'est assis plat
l'expriment à m'expliquer pourquoi du
duo de son chant expertise qui est de
loin supérieur au mien fait dans une
situation comme celle là tu écoutes
oui et puis je crois qu'on le fait pas
c'est je pense qu'on bloque trop
rapidement conversation a besoin non non
non non je brasse ou devrait on se place
aux jeunes j'ai un cousin un noir 150 il
y aussi ne se fera sans dire et bravo
pour ton attitude parce que c'est rare
pour de vrai les gens kiki c'est
vraiment aussi simple que cela dit
écoute essaie de comprendre reconnaît
l'expertisé de l'autre et moi ça
m'arrive aussi le de me faire traiter de
bain de me faire pas traité de
concession mais de me faire dire
et je peux être paternaliste cette façon
de voir les choses est peut-être à ses
soucis c'est vraiment injuste
v isite quoi j'avais pas vu seulement je
m'excuse c'est plus compliqué que ses
promenades dans un monde où ce que
j'habitais pas avec cette personne là
pas vraiment que j'aurais juste serait
juste parti j'avais terminé la division
automatiquement
je restais et mon opinion n'a pas changé
par rapport à mon du comportement
typique le c'est sûr que j'étais un peu
forcé faire face à cette conversation là
mais une seule différence en dire c'est
sexiste et raciste
où étaient ces cas tu dis tu es raciste
c'est comme tout son entièreté de taper
son nom c'est celui des poids au manque
de nuance dans notre façon de nous
exprimer
je le reconnais chez les militants ne
sont pas toujours habile ou adroit dans
leur façon de dénoncer des choses qui
m'aime moi j'allais pas toujours été
bien reçus pas toujours figé c'est le
team moines naturellement j'ai tendance
à une bavure pierre rome j'essaie de
faire attention à ça parce que je sais
que je veux me mettre du monde à dos les
jambes jeu au lieu dit convaincu que
j'allais faire se braquer ses nouveaux
comme apprentissage que pour moi puis
ccc beaucoup plus constructif par contre
ce que je trouve dommage là dedans c'est
que c'est à nous à faire des efforts
d'être plus poli agréable si les femmes
ossements on s'attend de nous qu'on soit
agréable souriant gentil qu'on dérange
pas c'est un peu ce que je fais pour
arriver à mes fins pour convaincre le
plus de monde possible
c'est comme un prix à payer pour
pas m'aligner trop de monde qui réussira
à atteindre mon objectif qui est de
convaincre les gens qu'il ya des
injustices leur faire faire connaître
d'échanger librement pas la méthode la
plus facile mais c'est certainement la
plus efficace si je comprends la colère
des autres de pauvres loi c 10 fois et
dans mon livre j'explique plusieurs
concepts utilisés par les militants dont
un qui s'appelle le ton
le temps pour les 5-6 police et le ton
la personne sa vie au lieu de au lieu de
de d'écouter ce que la personne a à dire
on va dire bah tu te prends pas de la
bonne façon pour me le dire mais en même
temps cette personne qui dénonce ce
qu'elle vise offre c'est comme puis
l'exemple que je donne pour illustrer la
tombe pas sous le pied de barnard ouais
j'ai du temps des mets donc ça illustre
dans le fond que même si c'est pas
habile mais ne s'est pas adroit
l'importance et d'écouté qui on l'a vu
dans l'actualité à plusieurs reprises et
par exemple en 2012
quand il y avait le conflit étudiants et
avait déjà qui disait qu il faut qu
c'est sur le fait que les étudiants
étaient un rougail des politiques a cédé
des affaires et ita billets étaient pour
la violence
et quand il est là il sans apporter
aucune aucune considération était bien
remplie pour tous ceux qui ont des
propos est totalement et polis et billy
ray sans doute minorité toujours le dis
toujours dit il toujours des pommes
pourries dans chacun des groupes paient
toujours du thé la connerie à la peau de
sexe ou de donner le nom l'artilleur
elle est présente partout de la même
façon qu'ici ça doit être ma les uns
pour les personnes
mettons qui est qu'ils sont plus à
droite de voir qu'il ya des hurluberlus
super raciste
oui inouïe pour la promotion des
mammouths
c'est que ben pour moi des fois de voir
des militants
mettons empêcher mathieu bock-côté de
s'exprimer non librairie à coup de on
peut maintenant on va être lancé si j'ai
dû donner des munitions
c'est exactement ce qui se passe c'est
mathieu bock côté on ne doit pas être
d'accord décliner mais c'est un
intellectuel les rats thématiques comme
crédit pareil le tango c'est quoi qui
parlent ils conservatory de droite
il doit s'exprimer de cépie ils tous qui
avez tout ce qu'ils allaient faire c'est
une conversation dans une librairie le
on fait des menaces on n'empêche c'est
toujours un choc électrique par rapport
à cet événement là était totalement
légitime c'est-à-dire que il y avait
c'était mathieu bock-côté face à un
internet interlocuteurs qu on peut
présumer quitté est d'accord avec lui
semblait être d'accord avec moi aussi le
faire qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
notre discussion est illégitime
je pense que je suis ok aussi sexiste
est dans un lieu qui était considéré
comme étant plus à gauche
quoique c'est est ce que vraiment une
librairie ou d'un positionnement
politique on ne sait pas mais je pense
qu on peut critiquer ces événements là
qu'on peut se rendre à l'évènement pour
dire je suis pas d'accord puis on peut
dire aussi que mathieu bock côté pour
quelqu'un qui dit qu'on peut plus rien
dire à beaucoup de tribus mais c'est ça
le camp il ya des camps il ya des
menaces beaucoup de tribu je la
comprends mais qui décide de dire à lui
être aux deux tribunes leur brillance
pas ça c'est que moi je n'ai pas empêché
d'avoir cette tribune et mais je peux
comprendre qu'on qu'il sait que son
discours son discours sur
essentiellement au peuple et on le
politically correct fait qu'on soit
policier discours et cetera alors que
c'est la personne qui en a qui fait
partie des personnes qui ont encore le
plus de tribunes des mots ce que je dis
souvent c'est que avec les réseaux
sociaux on a démocratisé la parole avant
c'était une sorte de personnes
essentiellement qui pouvait prendre la
parole dans l'espace public et des
décideurs des prêts d'un coup remonte
aux années 50
des animateurs de radio des journalistes
les vedettes
c'était des gens privilégiés aujourd'hui
la parole s'est démocratisée une femme
noire handicapé peut témoigner de son
expérience sur facebook et rassembler
autour d'elle des gens qui vivent la
même situation et créer un mouvement
c'est comme ça qu'on a eu des mouvements
comme mis tout comme dd ou des femmes se
sont mises ensemble et on réalise écrit
movie ce de manière commune on vit des
situations dont qui ont condom on parle
pas nécessairement dans les médias ce
qu'on peut mettre de l'avant pileux
c'est ça aussi que fait que créer une
espèce de renouveau du féminisme dans
les années 80 90 c'était comme un peu
gênant de dire qu'on était féministe
tout ça a permis à des nouvelles sortes
de personnes ne prennent la parole
et donc quand les gens disent on peut
plus rien dire réellement ce qu'ils
veulent dire ces on peut plus rien dire
comme avant sans se faire répond on n'a
plus le monopole de la parole
ouais peut être se gênant des rapports
de ses personnels de dire ça alors que
leur parole est encore parmi les plus
visibles puis aussi ce qu'on malgré
cette démocratisation le ce qu'on voit
c'est que les personnes qui étaient
marginalisés avant qu'ils n'avaient pas
leur place dans un discours public
continue de subir davantage de barrières
à la prise de parole c'est à dire
qu'elles vont être davantage
elles vont faire davantage l'objet de
commentaires malveillants elles vont
être assis dans un coin ridiculiser et
cetera caricaturé comme on disait plutôt
donc je trouve que je trouve que c'est
bien et descendez dit on peut parier moi
je peux me faire l'avocat de mathieu
bock-côté je choisis un fan de mathieu
bock côté je trouve qu'il ait failli
écrire les articles de merde je trouve
que des fois il écrit des articles sens
et aussi par contre je pense qu'il y ait
eu beaucoup lui qui beaucoup entendu
parce qui écrit beaucoup tes écrits
beaucoup puis mais c'est sa phase
réseaux sociaux ou par le journal québec
j'en ai marre est en mairie peau
je me souviens pas l'avoir vu à ce qu il
va sortir un livre il parlait maintenant
at home en a pas ils peuvent pas le tout
en laissant libre après l'émission ça
c'est vrai métier plus souvent invité à
parler en france qu'au québec nous
n'osions pas qui il est poli pas non
plus comme accueillent à bras ouverts au
québec comme je pense que c'est une
grande source de frustration pour lui
parce que je pense qu'il souhaiterait
être plus reconnu par le médiatique
québécoise était lecture en fête parce
que s'il ya une distinction quand même
forte entre les est intellectuelle pi
l'élite médiatique
tu peux créer un mémorial mais pas être
considérée par l'état dicte harcèlement
si je disais maintenant
être invité à plus on est de fous plus
au lycée une tre prestigieuse soirée
reconnaissance ccc je pense que ces
chroniques carlos du journal de montréal
sont peut-être frustrés ne pas avoir ces
tribunes et en même temps une grande
part de responsabilité dans le fait
qu'ils appartiennent à l'empiré quebecor
d'une autre forme de visibilité je pense
qu'il ya encore des guerres médiatiques
qui fait en sorte que même ben oui c'est
ça que les artistes de quebecor sont
gardés chez quebecor pis même si ça fait
pas l'objet nécessairement d'antan
écrite
il reste qu'il ya des chasses gardées il
ya des gens qui sont pub les bienvenus
dans l'élan pires d'europe pas que c'est
complet pour qui ces gens là aussi à
défaut d'avoir des tribunes qui sont
prestigieux sur le plan intellectuel
dans la symbolique du - bellion des
tribunes qui sont ultra populaire qui
rejoignent très largement le petit
mathieu bock-côté moins à la télé et à
la radio au québec mais mettons richard
martin ou encore t'es son temps
d'antenne puis son temps de parole est
immense il en est il dans des émissions
à tvi et son émission et que brad y sont
sa tribune quotidienne au journal de
montréal
c'est beaucoup j'avais pour rebondir sur
cette idée là j'avais l'addiction
encore une fois avec ma blonde par
rapport au fait que justement la place
publique était pris principalement au
québec par des gens privilégient danse
du singe sont privilégiés avec des
blancs pas démunis qui sont qui ont
cette tribune la puis moi ma réflexion
première était de dire
avec justement que l'on parlait la
décapite démocratisation de la parole
tout le monde a le droit de prendre sa
place des dettes et coûté par contre
quand tu regardes les faits c'est pas
les minorités qui sont écoutés dans les
cotes d'écouté mais dont le ca reste
encore aux gens privilégiés puis la
réflexion était de me dire est ce qu'il
ya une responsabilité des instances de
qui dirige tout ça de mettre en place
des gens qui sont pas privilégiés pour
leur donner la parole sur des tribunes
qui sont déjà acquis est ce que c'est ce
que c'est c'est une solution à la
chercher la diversité dans la parole
publique
mais il ya premièrement il ya une
responsabilité partagée comme on faisait
plutôt star system donc tu es je veux
donner le meilleur exemple de ce qu'on
dénonce là il ya des gens qui ont
dénoncé le fait qu qui est juste des
blancs nommé au gala c'est à moi et je
ne suis pas bon exemple parce que le
gala artis
c'est un gala qui est qui célèbre en
fait les choix populaire donc c'est les
gens qui votent vedettes préférées
puis on sait que c'est en fait un
concours de popularité qui est beaucoup
déterminé par ton temps d'antenne pita
visibilité médiatique
plus tu fais une émission que des
grosses cotes d écoute plus de chances
d'être avancée dans ce palmarès le de
popularité donc
yj dans par mini commentera cette
nouvelle loi et des gens qui dénoncent l
aile le manque de diversité parmi les
nommés il ya une femme qui disait c'est
ridicule s'ils avaient des lois on
aurait voté pour
c'est pas ça pourra pas de notre faute
mais comment ça se fait que peu de noirs
ou cap à deux pas de diversité c'est
parce qu'on met pas beaucoup les
personnes assises et dans les postes de
premier plan dans les post it pas c'est
pas à ce que disait c'est si c'était un
work animer la poule où elle n'est pas
la poule aux oeufs d'or
salut bonjour ouais ça lui cécile gino
chouinard et danois on aurait voté pour
lui c'est parce que c'était ce que
disait la madame qui c'est ça le
problème en fait comme ça se fait une
joie non les premiers sacs ou là le
problème c'est la couleur de nos
diffuseurs mais pas de l'avant des
personnes assises et puis pourquoi ils
en mettent pas belle passe qui est
souvent ce qu'ils disent c'est qu'un
trouve pop pourquoi on trouve pas parce
que les gens se voit pas donc il faut
pas les critiques
on va prendre un peu là la balle au bond
sur la poule aux oeufs d'or c'est un peu
la pole avant l'oeuf les caisses qu'est
ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on fait est ce
que c'est on a on a nos minots gala
artis pour que du monde se voit pour que
du monde de l offre qui pensent qu'il
faut travailler plus en amont que ce
puits considérant les barrières que ces
gens le vivent pour accéder aux mêmes
opportunités que tout le monde
on devrait faire pour le temps que c'est
nécessaire dépôt des paramédics d
encourager cette diversité le but faire
des efforts supplémentaires quand on
fait un casting
moi je vois des fois des castings cole
qui s'est un peu c'est un peu débile
pour de vrai comme on dit
comme on n'est pas à jour par rapport
maître au milieu anglophone ou par
rapport au milieu américaine si c'est
comme on va demander des caucasiens et
on va dire peut être noir et on va
présenter au on va présenter et deux
groupes deux cas cités on va dire pour
voici le casting pour le personnage de
tel
et voici le casting diversité mettons
que ça vous tenterait d'anti pour juste
des mots qu'ont les uns aux 10 ciani sur
le 800 lors les auditionner jusqu'à
n'était pas à la hauteur c'est commencer
puis après ça bassin c'est aussi parce
que
mettons que tu veux
si tu veux les comédiens connus dans ta
série pour la mousseline loin parce que
les grosses écuries risque en plus des
comédiens sont connus plus tu vas avoir
de succès comme va attirer des gens les
gens de la diversité sont ses
déhanchements inconnue donc c'est plus
un risque c'est plus t'es pas qui je
pense qu'il faut faire des efforts
supplémentaires qui donner plus
d'opportunités qui favorise et ça puisse
poser vraiment les questions bien céder
c'est à cléon il dit c'est la chance oui
mais face aux faucons pour qu'on voit le
problème pour agir dessus puis se donner
les contraigne dit pas essayer de les
contourner ces contraintes le e
ouais c'est évident qu'un problème de
diversité plus de représentativité dans
les maisons opté à l'écran général que
la demo de faux j'ai un peu et il ya
quand même la diversité d'opinion même
si mettons il n'y a pas de diversité
- - diversité de couleurs où tu peins
pas c'est
puis le concept des privilèges c'est pas
non plus parce que tous les privilèges
qui était un anneau ou kate on regroupe
les gens à en groupe le testament c'est
l'effet les femmes les rendre à 6 et
handicapées les intimes
moi personnellement les privilèges des
tout bons paris et médecin chef blanche
et hétérosexuels les écouter est-ce que
ça discrédite ma parole avant même que
j'ai ouvert la bouche je pense pas
qu'ils aient ce que j'ai quelque chose
en commun avec mettons sujet prenant
beaucoup plus en commun avec toi nous
dit dick avec richard matis nous
demandez pas qui ça définit poffo fait
attention de pas de prix prix définitif
jamais sait jamais ce dont il est
question quand on parle le privilège par
contre si tu es une grande diversité
d'opinion c'est vrai mais pas une grande
diversité de perspectives qui ont des
personnalités du jeu trouve en fonction
de nos sensibilités mais c'est sûr que
moi mettons ça fait des années que je
parle des personnes trans
c'est un sujet qui me tient car j'en
connais plusieurs j'essaie d'être une
bonne à l'ip de mènera de l'avant leur
ans jules tels que moi je les perçois
mais les personnes trans vivent des
problématiques que je peux pas imaginer
qu'on prend sur leurs perspectives et
jamais mises de l'avant parce que en ce
moment au québec il ya aucune personne
trans que deux tribunes régulière donc
c'est à chaque fois qu'on consomme et
pitt et mettons on peut dire beaucoup de
choses sur les personnes trans leur
récemment les yeux une série à canal vie
il ya eu des documentaires à télé-québec
et honneur yauque eglin jenner et pis
en même temps quand je parle à des
personnes trans ils me disent ouais mais
tu y mettons ces séries là sa focus
beaucoup sur les transitions génitales
l'a fait pape à sa part pas tant que
sonne notre réalité issa oublie de
mentionner plein de réalités qui font
vraiment partie maintenant de notre
communauté par exemple la prostitution
les personnes assises et qui vise au
danger supplémentaire et et puis en fait
ça ça montre que représentent les
réalités transmet toujours de notre
perspective à nous de gens qui ne vivent
pas ici perfectible ces situations le
maxi karim je trouve que karim il savait
pas dire que ma parole est invalide par
rapport aux anges je trouve mais il faut
pas qu'elle est juste la mienne bon je
fais du mieux que j'ai pu mais il ya des
choses que je vois pas tous nos
engagements nos identités qu'on le
veuille ou non eu
et faire en sorte qu'on ait saison le
mans là qu'on voit pas nécessairement
les choses toujours nous y danser nous
des finisseurs n'ont absolument pas
parce que tu le biais d' il ya beaucoup
plus de sûrement de d'éléments qui
rassemble de penser qu'ils ont un toit
puis richard martineau mais si je trouve
pas qu'on peut se contenter de ça comme
signe d'une diversité qui je pense que
tu es même si je suis je suis bien
intentionnés et puis que je dis la
parole de femmes blanches en ce moment
dans les médias y en a il y en a
beaucoup
alors oui un corps d'homme blanc betty
je pense qu'il y aurait de la place pour
d'autres choses pour d'autres
perspectives
j'aime vraiment la distinction en tant
opinion vis perspective librement
quelque chose là puis ça me fait penser
à dernièrement d'un courant féministe
il ya une pensée c'est encore une fois
jesse kim kim m'expliquer ce qu'il pense
et qui dit que les hommes peuvent pas
nécessairement à être féministe peuvent
être ralliés à la cause mais peuvent pas
se définir comme féministe justement
parce que te pas la perspective là la
femme mais tu peux est allié à la cause
oui c'en est seulement de dire je te
dirai que cette nuance la haye est assez
présente plus en milieu universitaire
parce que je pense que pour le grand
public
c'est confondant puisse impliquer belle
si c'est comme cela les deux motos mora
dans ce pays personne ne convainc pas
non je pourrais comprendre que ça fasse
comme les moyens on the north bay
et c'est demain compliqué finalement
inclusif
oui c'est ça en même temps ça c'est
intéressant tu sais je sais il ya une
autre chose qui fait souvent qui
discrédite le mouvement féministe c'est
justement les choses
les réunions non mixtes qui il ya
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes qui
comprennent pas pourquoi parfois les
féministes ressentent le besoin de se
réunir entre femmes qui c'est parce que
historiquement les féministes ont
remarqué dans des réunions deux
féministes que les dynamiques de pouvoir
tendait à se reproduire que tu y avait
un homme dans la salle pas parce que
c'est une mauvaise personne mais parce
qu'on a été socialisés différemment pige
généralement les hommes sont on les
encourage dès leur plus jeune âge après
leur place à être des leaders alors que
les femmes on valorise d'autres choses
bien souvent la g2 pouvait être latéral
discussion pouvait dévier ou les réels
besoins des femmes est peut-être moins
1000 avant puis ou que les mettons un
homme finissait par prendre le
leadership sur une non dans un meeting
où est exactement et ont réalisé que
parfois pas toujours mais à l'occasion
sa prendre un moment pour nous réunir
entre nous et un autre une façon
d'illustrer cette cette situation le t
on dirait on s'offusque crée pas de dire
qu'une réunion syndicale doit se faire
sans les patrons c'est sans dire que les
hommes sont les patrons des femmes josé
s'est dit on vit des enjeux qui sont
différents qu'il faut pouvoir se réunir
en nous pour pouvoir en parler librement
sans sentir jugé ici comme là en ce
moment je dis ça je sais que votre
podcast est écouté par des hommes par
des femmes par les gens qui sont plus
politisé par des gens pour qui le
féminisme ce nouveau sujet je sais que
des gens qui sont
par les avis pourraient mener elles vont
avoir le 7 mai je pourrais avoir envie d
fois de parler plus librement et télé je
pèse mes mots
attention met des gants blancs je
pourrais avoir envie avec mes jeunes
féministes qu'on parle sans gants blancs
qu'on dise les vraies choses puis après
attention formule quelque chose d'un peu
plus nuancé oui c'est comme un bébé d'un
groupe à l'école de danse vous puis
amène une porte-parole veut pas voir
toutes vos idées que l'analogie entre
mettant les syndicalistes qui on avait
trempé les patrons ouais c'est un peu de
dire
tron est conique quelle raison les
femmes sont unis qui sont tous
féministes qui les hommes le sont pas
une métaphore mais ses propos des femmes
peu féministe witham qui sont beaucoup
plus faibles qu'à moi c'est les classes
beaucoup plus tous les gens qui
considèrent que les fans de rallye des
droits décoder des sommes perçues ce
qu'il pense pas puis dans six groupes
liés au temps des femmes qui les sommes
que des personnes de toutes sortes de
minorités qui sont vrais enseignements
absolument pis même des parmi les
féministes on n'a pas toujours si on
pourrait se réunir entre féministes mais
exclure des femmes parce qu'il n'ya pas
pensé classique il peut pas considérer
leurs enjeux comme étant prioritaire
c'est qu'ils savaient pas dire que ça
veut poser des règles claires et
précises et des sans nuance je pense
pipi de l'importance de dire que la non
mixité c'est pas quelque chose c'est pas
un mode de fonctionnement
qu'ils perdent qui doit être permanente
c'est quelque chose que des fois t'es
mon petit des fois se réunit mobilité je
pense que les gens rapidement ils se
sentent exclus qui sont pas à l'aise
avec ça
puis effectivement l'analogie patrons et
syndicats a fait pour eux c'est limite
mais lorsque la question la question
reste intéressant trouve de chez que
dans le véganisme et un groupe facebook
c'est comme le pour qu'ils gagnent plus
25 puis ce groupe là il faut y croire
vraiment puis jamais la vie gan police
jamais de la vie je voudrais que
quelqu'un de mon entourage qui
s'intéresse à mon mode de vie tombe sur
cette page qui considère que ceux ci les
talents sont un excellent exemple ce que
tu es je suis très bien que mes
positions doivent être nuancés quand
j'ai exprimé un grand public quand
j'écris maintenant je te donne un autre
exemple moi dans mes chroniques j'ai
fait là j'ai fait le choix depuis
utilisé le mot patriarcat parce que
c'est souvent mal compris ce à brac les
gens les gens sont convaincus que j'aï
les hommes quand je dis ce mot là et si
j'écris dans un ouvrage universitaire de
sociologie féministe d'autres choses un
concept qui comprit qui est établi que
les gens savent douche pas mais c'est
pareil avec ton groupe viggen ce genre
c'est quoi au bois petit tu manges du
miel c'est sûr qu'à des lieux où c'est
plus est propice
oui mais parfois ces groupes là ça
devient des terreaux de réalisation
oui des fois c'est en parlant sont les
pistes une situation que j'avais déjà lu
l'article en question d'une fille qui
était dans un groupe féministe que les
groupes rapidement la dynamique steak
avec 2,3 et l'équipement contrôle chez
mais toutes les autres femmes
si tu avais de porter des jets en 2002 6
13 la malchance radical côté pile c'est
l'ironie c'est que c'est on appelle ça
des six pay ce qui est parfois j'imagine
que j'ose croire que ces minorités des
fois mais parfois ça devient tout sauf
simple ça demande un suspect jusqu'à
temps que ça ne soit plus en plus à
l'aise à cette place
sûrement que ça mord aux dents dans le
pont à quel point les dynamiques de
poires tendent à se reproduire dans ses
cinq sens les des gens qui peut-être
subissent des abus dans leur vie
reproduit ces abus leur pit et on n'a
pas le contrôle là dessus des serments
et vous effectivement les nommer plus
dénoncés illzach y montrer que la va
trop loin
moi j'étais en train de
dernièrement je plongerai of force on ma
maîtrise je parle du véganisme en tant
que tel de l'activisme vegan mai
pas un fait en montrant toutes les
nuances de d'activistes puis en
critiquant aussi certains certains
agissements à l'intérieur
moi je me rappelle j'étais allé à une
vigie est là au canada goose
devant le canada goose pour l'abolition
la fourrure le défaire de fourrure puis
il y en a dans ce groupe lucky qui
envoyait littéralement chez des gens qui
passaient avec un manteau fille de la
fourrure c'est sur leur manteau moi ça
m'a écoeuré idée genre de manifestation
là ça m'a écoeuré de ce que ça
représente et parce que je voyais toutes
les autres qui venaient une pancarte
sans dire un mot avec des faits qui
faisait son ultra passivement puis que
la police était là tout le monde tu
laisses des relaxes pitt avait 2-3 qui
faisait juillet puis le gars qui se fait
cris après il revient chez eux hidipo
haye avait de manière vraiment pas ça
chauffe qui me sens pas il est au crâne
de colis de vegan qui m'ont cris après
jamais de la vie ce que l'oeuvre où
cette personne là va s'ouvrir à une
opinion qui t'ai dit écoute le monde en
parle devant jean philippe sire parler
du véganisme probablement la meilleure
entrevue de tout le monde en parle
depuis ils veulent juste part au nom
l'autre s'ils gagnent alors que le
message qu'ils m'aiment le le message is
tout se séparent festival ouvrira cette
discussion là mais le lui ça va juste
sept personnels ça va juste bloqués à
cause de cet incident précise l'odm et
oui tout un entourage ou suspendre le
débat sur slave qui avait des critiques
souvent légitimes qui étaient formulées
à l'endroit du processus créatif mais tu
avais des gens qui attendait les
spectateurs de mon théâtre ont leur
criant raciste c'est sûr que si pas la
meilleure façon de convaincre des gens
que c'est pour petite famille qui reçut
des biotopes même les spectateurs qui
dit ben moi je vois rim par ma propre
opinion je vais aller voir nos rues
moitié des raisons légitimes ou des gens
se place sur un spectre plus ou moins
politi et ça fait pas deux comme tu
disais tantôt une différence entre dire
tu es raciste pis aussi raciste c'est
super différencient comme la meilleure
façon de ne pas convaincre du monde les
accuser directement être beaucoup plus
est succès puis beaucoup plus
stratégique à mon avis et il y avait des
critiques et ses supports valable comme
tu dis du spectacle love qui mérite
réflexion
mais il ya aussi une frange de ses
militants le qui utilisent la thune
d'utiliser son droit de parole pour
empêcher l'eau de voir son droit de
parole tant qu'à moi c'est pas d'accord
parce que tu mets jamais été question
d'empêcher le droit de parole de qui que
ce soit les lipper puma mais il ya des
gens qui ont un mac peuvent attaquer ya
une personne qui dit en fait il ya une
personne qui te porte parole de
d'un des groupes militants le quitter à
la manifestation que dit on veut pas non
mais y avait de la pression pour que le
feu soit le jazz and l'inspecteur mais
les militants de la majorité des
militants on peut demander l'annulation
du spectacle c'est un amalgame et à on
veut annuler le spectacle la majorité
des militants faisaient on veut
critiquer cet espace le puits quand tu
disais tu es je trouve ça dommage que
ces gens là utilisent utilise voir toute
parole et en ont déjà tellement peur que
tu es alors que quand on regardait les
gens qui s'exprimait sur ce live majeurs
et dans les médias une majorité là comme
90% étaient blancs les piles les deux
trois personnes racisées qui était qui
lyon qui se sont exprimés vraiment dans
l'espace public parmi soleil avec
fabrice ville qui venait d'être envoyé
au journal le devoir qui étaient
rappelés en renfort pour s'exprimer sur
cette cette polémique là ça montre à
quel point on a un problème de diversité
des médias blain qui s'exprime ce des
sujets qui touchent les communautés
racisées c'est ya vraiment une inégalité
dans les tribunes fac après ça qu'on en
pointant du doigt puis qu'on dise il
veut nous empêcher de parler alors qu'on
est tellement en majorité des personnes
qui va nous empêcher de parler
dans les faits ces festivals que change
que 10 millions pour des raisons un peu
le choix là mais j'ai aucun problème
avec le fait j'ai aucun problème le fait
que de manifester aucun problème je
pensais c'est essentiel dans la société
j'encourage et déjà manifestés moi même
j'ai aucun problème
le fait d'écrire une chronique d'écrire
un texte qui critique
jolin 100% c'est juste alors secundo ce
qu'on dit on doit annuler son cette
personne devrait pas parler comme un
baume année 200 millions du contraire
fac une hausse il faut considérer le
rapport des forces en présence
puis la personne qui ne se fait aucune
crédibilité dans ce sens que je veux pas
minimiser la portée de sa parole mais
c'est pas à cette personne qu'on donne
du crédit
la raison pour laquelle le festival a
annulé slave
c'est pour des raisons stratégiques
commerciales voulait pas avoir de
troubles mais à chaque fois qu'on prend
la parole on fait le calcul des coûts et
bénéfices et on décide si oui ou non ça
vaut la peine de s'exprimer
socke est en fait l'expérience et plein
de fois où tu dis ashvind j'aimerai sa
publié ça mais et compte tenu que je
m'adresse à ce que je fais parce que
j'aimerais faire
oui exactement c'est sûr qu'on s'auto
censurer comme si 10 des fois on n'a pas
le choix mais on fait le choix de bord
est resté derrière ce lave pendant
longtemps jusqu'à temps que sans que ça
déborde
un regard international qui pouvait me
citer le saura si cela vous si cette
fois c'était très amalgamix bête c'est
peut-être aussi accusé des états mais
c'est
m
c'est la mission qui a annulé son
spectacle en raison de ce témoin me
questionne
mais c'est son choix puisque oui c'est
son choix mais qu'est ce que ce que la
décision est vraiment pris en
connaissance de cause dans tout ce débat
l'oeil peu de gens ont vu le spectacle
mais je comprends les critiques à la
limite de thé en fait je suis d'accord
avec les critiques le fait que qui
devrait avoir plus de personnes noires à
l'intérieur au spectacle hull city la
première chose que robert lepage a fait
pas la première les eaux il commençait
par laisser passer deux semaines à
commencer par strictement on va
s'asseoir on va discuter
oui j'ai eu une bonne attitude
d'ouverture mais
car tu dis la plupart de ces gens leur
ont pas vu le spectacle je pense à
marine kraft qui était la blogueuse que
initier la réflexion sur cela dans son
texte elle reconnaissait que sa critique
porté sur le discours entourant le
spectacle et non sur le spectacle
qu'elle n'avait évidemment pas lui pas
vu parce qu'ils n'étaient pas 10 ms et
des cantons présentent quand on parle
d'un spectacle on dit on est déjà en
train de discourir sur ce qu'il sait sur
l'objet culturel
après c'est elle a été traînée dans la
boue la part des des chroniqueurs qui
ont tellement blues de pouvoir quelle
méthode nathalie petrowski lol le
traiter comme une espèce de cervolix pas
vu le spectacle se permet de critiquer
sans avoir vu alors que marilou
accueille 7 et apprécier les jeunes ne
ne lisent que nathalie petrowski parce
que alors beaucoup plus plus de pouvoir
une très une tribune beaucoup plus
puissantes et se font une idée de
marilou kraft à travers le regard de
nathalie petrowski était très sévère et
est déjà rendu au deuxième niveau de
réflexion absolument pour revenir à
l'artiste qui a annulé son spectacle
josé c'est un choix personnel que tu
peux faire lui c'est priver de revenus
s'est pris une opportunité c'est privé
comment pression peut l'accuser
ce que je trouve dommage c'est que
souvent les personnes qui dénoncent ce
qu'ils perçoivent comme des injustices
en paix beaucoup plus le prix qu'est ce
qu'on ce qu'on voudrait y croire alors
qu'on a l'impression que si j'en retire
des bénéfices août
bon ce pour leurs propres et pour se
donner de la valeur aux peaux
je pense que ces gens là font ça parce
qu'ils vivent des injustices on relève
besoin de les nommer 20 cas précis je
trouve ça et pis je ne suis pas
important de considérer vraiment
pas juste les mots qui sont dits miracle
pouvoir derrière ces mots là les gens
quitter pau une personne est la personne
qui dit les mois on aimerait mieux que
le spectacle sont animistes c'est un
jeune homme noir reste et trans racisées
et 010 est pas lui dont dans quoi que ce
soit qui s est dit qu un autre affaire
qui était invité du catcheur calibre aux
été évitée à tout le monde en parle pour
parler de ça avec betty bonifassi sont
les vitesses il ya été désinvité ya
personne qui a fait un scandale avec ça
alors il ya quelqu'un il y avait une
femme qui le mouvement grand oui mais
comment ça se fait qu'on dit on préfère
on préfère donner la parole à une femme
qui a adhéré à la proposition de betty
bonifassi cas quelqu'un qui est encore
contre en qui encore des critiques à
formuler à cet endroit il ya quand même
quelque chose là dedans je dois comme
les gens qui font cette décision lui qui
prend cette décision là ont un pouvoir
de mettre de l'avant des perspectives
dont celle qui qui qui caricaturent iep
qui est vu comme étant extrêmement lui a
pas donné l'occasion d'aller expliquer
si c'est les préoccupations à une
mission qui est une très grande tribu
donc chaud faut faire attention quand on
évalue les discours de mesurer ils le
pouvoir des acteurs c'est peut-être un
peu le même principe que quand même
temps tu lis des commentaires sur une
photo pc le commentaires agressifs
négatif qui te sautent au visage en
premier les commentaires nuancés autre
suspense suspense - mais il ya les
algorithmes qui entrent en ligne de
compte le premier temps sur facebook les
commentaires les plus populaires les
plus laïcs et arrive en premier ça dit
quelque chose sur l'outil salsa c'est
intéressant à observer mais des fois
c'est les plus extrêmes et les
algorithmes et a fait comme il est mais
j'ai tissé souvent les conflits qui
vient en premier
en sortant de la question slave mousse
qui me dérange dans le fond ce souvent
ce que j'observe c'est qu'un qui a
beaucoup qui les gens qui embarquent
dans des mouvements
houda d
dans des événements qui prennent
position pikit certaines personnes
disent pas tout le monde qui est que la
réflexion aussi aboutis ou nuancer ou
epci ou à point qui mettons la marelle
ou d'autres pas et puis des fois ça crée
des aberrations c'est maintenant aux
états unis stelly les petits gains avec
leur casquette est la garantie que le
dans le court extrait il semblait se
moquer d'un autochtone ça fait le tour
des réseaux sociaux comment se braquer
des acteurs d'idées des personnes aux
états unis qui twitte ont donné leur nom
on va lécher mais en public nanar ça va
très très loin qui l'a finalement obs 80
quand t'écoutes la vidéo complet se rend
compte que le contexte du tout se fixer
ces petits gazouillis ont rien demandé
puis on peut vraiment rien fait de mal
non plus tant pis le hall s'excuse new
york times on s'excuse on savait pas à
la lumière de nouvelles informations
el maati la vidéo compliqué toujours et
toujours existé ces mots des situations
comme ça je me dis ok tout le monde et
tout le monde est embarqué dans le train
demandez au thé en train sans faire
l'analyse sans réfléchir qui c'est allé
beaucoup trop loin c'est cepgl eux ils y
ont dû vivre une détresse crier c'est
des petits gosses des deee pro trump
blancs américains à d'autres auxquelles
on aucune sympathie à la mort c'est
l'apathie qassam et un autre beaucoup
plus d'empathie
on dirait pour ces jeunes eux que pour
marilou venons d'entendre seconde en ce
moment tu 2b oui parce que tu prend leur
défense tu dis à lyon était mal
représentés et marilou aussi a été
maintes fois peut-être maîtrisé
reconnaissons que celle-ci jeune garçon
là qu'ils ont l'air gentil car malgré
leur casque et on la reçoit beaucoup
plus d'empathie j'ai l'impression que
bach loup qui comme pogné avec le fait
qu' elle soit associée malgré elle à des
discours qu dont elle n'est pas
responsable mais je fais pas le jeu je
n'ai pas de prendre en défaut je voulais
pas remarqué qu'on a tendance à jouer
autant d'empathie pour marilou dès
demain mais je crois qu'il faut le new
york times s'est pas excusé personnes
comment le new york times et le notw
l'équivalent d'une oqtf doit pas fait
l'apologie de marilou dozois seppi moi
j'en ai entendu beaucoup parler de ce
revers de la médaille le comme quoi qui
ça a été trop instrumentalisée pour
discréditer les choses pour dire que
sont encore une fois allé trop loin que
c'est important de regarder le revers de
la médaille je vois pas non si je trouve
que la critique alain vers cette affaire
aussi le jeu souvent aidé iliad et on
reproche des des faits à des personnes
des militants de gauche puis on regarde
pas le revers de la médaille puis on ne
peut pas y apparaître s'cusez dû d'abord
mal présenté une situation moi je trouve
que il ya beaucoup d'empathie pour ce
jeune homme là que je ne vois pas
nécessairement pour des militants de
gauche mais je m'excuse je voulais pas
que tu avais plus d'un tas de noms mais
pour marilou non mais je pense qu'on
sait peut-être mal compris parce que moi
je suis les critiques pour slave
je les comprends qu'ils jugent les
limites je les supporte le thé jus je
comprends les critiques de fond sauf que
je suis convaincu que dans ce mouvement
qu'on a tous les mouvements d'une
personne qui embarquent dans le train
sans trop réfléchir
c'est sûr que les étiquettes mais quand
même façon qu'on dit elle je peux pour
que manon massé veux qu'on dise
matrimoine c'est la même chose des deux
côtés il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit pour faire attention aux perceptions
qui nuancé mais il faut réfléchir il
faut il faut savoir se qualifie dans une
situation dans toutes les situations
je sais pas parce que tous à tout se
ramène un peu au point initial qui était
de dire qu'on a pu
en tant que société le désir d'aller en
profondeur dans un d'approfondir notre
notre idée avant de prendre position
puis je sais pas qui est ce qui serait
une meilleure façon de
partager l'information
en fait maintenant avec avec kylie un
article
après avoir vu un petit jeu c'est le
plus possible mais souvent trop dont fit
d'un article telle affaire dont on en
parle avec la matrix sénégal le l'auteur
qui est accusé de pédophilie
voici sa disparation des notions de
ponctuation suffit de lui
le xv de la rose est important de mettre
les nuages le site de l'arctique c'était
un auteur accusé de distribution de
pornographie juvénile
sans ça riendeau
on a l'impression que c'était
l'impression que le gain de points sur
son ordi ça tout le monde le sait dans
quoi web alors que quand tu lis
l'article c'est tellement j'ai
l'impression que c'est juste un exemple
un microcosme de quelque chose de bien
ce fléau au lion révolution devrait
effectivement quelqu'un issu d'un green
où j'ai l'impression parce que même moi
je vais jamais commenter un article sans
l'avoir lu
par contre comme tu dis tout ce qu ont
fait les beaux jours tous les articles
pas sûr tous les articles et
effectivement c'est une vision du monde
à partir d'articles de cette rixe ont
bien souvent des cliques ben exact qui
sont ici on est dans les 6m de ce jeu ma
gêne que toi quand tu écris tu dois
réfléchir attentif le post ouais mais je
suis pas très habile pour être honnête
parce qu'on a pas j à mener et mon
pupitre a même expliqué que notre notre
site le vraiment le droit 3,4 molloy une
fois c'est plus comme très forte dans le
clip beat je pourrais faire mieux ben
oui ce droit
sauf que ça
quelles limites une limite ni sling a
marché si on veut tout en la vidant les
types plus choc puis plus punchy ça ça
contribue encore à la présentation pas
utiliser les armes complètement perdre
en latin c'est toi qu'on doit laisser
reparle de mathieu bock côté le commencé
à écrire le groupe de tête
ça fait des années qu'ils touchent dans
le montréal cmm avancées y écrivait dans
d'autres dans notre tribune qui si
c'était s'était dit long article aussi
est étoffé avec eux avec la nuance puis
avec tes un titre qui tu vois ce que le
clairement avec le temps ces dix
personnes qui limite à faire le focus
john cho d iran duel 14 caricature de
lui même puis écrit un gros titre choc
avec quelques titres aux punchers c'est
son article 6 au 10 août ces trains d'un
journal moyenne mais ça fait partie de
leur forme je pense pas que ce soit
nécessairement lui qui décide d'écrire
comme ça mais des fois les sous titres
je trouve tellement racoleur parce que
les angolais 6 grille juste abandonné la
réflexion ou du moins d'en semer dieu
mes yeux le pour des trucs puncher
populaire puisque maintenant belge parce
que si on n'y échappe pas là quand on
rejoint un média c'est très difficile
pour de vrai de garder totalement son
authenticité de sa couleur
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de on irait
de beaucoup de façons de faire des jeux
de ce média à métro pour des vrais gens
me semble pourtant que ce rapport que
j'ai informé très très réduit le g 500
mo black swan sa vie même en fait c'est
400 mais j'en mangeais tire tout temps
jusqu'à 500 mètres 6 6 2 sans fond on
s'appelle et rex
en fait avec le format dans lequel on
écrit puis on sait à quel public on
s'adresse pitié
moi j'apprends de s'infecter magie des
mots que j'utilise plus sans devenir
populisme et à essayer d'être toujours
accessible c'est un médium quand même
par delà le journal gratuit distribué
dans le métro
plus précisément des neurones ont
rejoint vraiment tout le monde donc mais
récemment j'ai réussi à faire un peu de
politique ligue b c'était un symbole
d'oppression
je les lui assez bons sur les soul elle
les soutiens-gorge mettait dans l'est
dans les temps qui courent c'est une
expression qu'on utilise beaucoup parlé
du voile mais l'arctique et je ne m a
pas aussi oui je dois l'avouer mais en
même temps je trouve que c'est des
réalités le voile et le soutien gorge
qui se compare pas pour de vrai et là
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'utilise
jamais le mot voile dans mon article je
trouve que c'est vraiment deux réalités
différentes sauf que je pense que quand
on dit que le voile est un symbole de
pression on omet de reconnaître chez
nous nos symboles de pression à cause
qu'ils appartiennent à notre culture
il nous choque moins mégalo leur soutien
gorge le maquillage c'est autant de
symboles qui peuvent être des symboles
de pression que ça veut pas dire quand
on nomme quelque chose comme un symbole
d'oppression que c'est quelque chose à
abolir
ça veut juste dire pour reconnaître que
ce ça peut renaître puis ça peut ne pas
l'être au cinéma qui pour toutes sortes
de raisons ça veut dire que je te comme
soumise aux dictatures du patriarcat
ça veut dire que c'est des choix qu'on
fait dans une société qu'ils sont
tant qu'ils sont influencés par la
culture ne veut pas dire qu'on ait des
victimes là dedans mais il faut
reconnaître que l'on fait possible on se
lève pas un matin en se maquillant parce
qu'il ya aucune oppression social binty
il ya des raisons pour lesquelles on
fait ça c'est clair qu'il ya des gens
qui sont forcés de porter des soutiens
gorge
à partir de là est ce que c est ce qu
une société moins féministe parce que
dans certains et parce qu'il ya des
femmes qui sont forcés de porter des
soutiens gorge alors que là on est
vraiment vraiment prêt à juger
facilement leur les cultures chez qui
une pression pour porter le voile
je trouve qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures moyens double standard non je
n'avais jamais
n'avait jamais pris connaissance de ce
fait qu tivement c'est vraiment est ce
la seule la seule chose qui dérange en
fait c'est que le voile soit célestin
gauche senghor c'est comment dire
une norme culturelle son voeu outin
tandis qu'ils se mettent pas un symbole
religieux mais c'est exactement la
raison pour laquelle je disais qu'on
peut pas vraiment la comparaison
s'arrête là parce que moi je trouve que
le fait que ce soit un symbole religieux
et ajoute une couche de sara lee
la question des droits fondamentaux déjà
important parce que c'est un droit
fondamental pratiquer sa religion mais
c'est ça fait aussi que ben on évacue le
fait que le voile puissent être
également en plus d'être un objet
religieux puis c'est également un objet
culturel riche pas mal certaines qui lui
sont faites
oui puis je peux m'en certaine qu'il ya
des femmes qui portent le voile pour
toutes sortes de raisons qui sont
pimpantes même pot religieuse qui
j'aimerais c'est peut-être malhabile
mais une façon j'essaie de voir que
j'essaye de comprendre si des fois c'est
maintenant que j'avais grandi dans une
culture où les femmes à partir d'un
certain âge porte le voile
de la même façon où j'ai grandi dans une
culture où à partir d'un certain âge les
filles on couvre on cache notre poitrine
si j'étais dans un environnement où on
me forçait à pas cacher ma poitrine je
serais pas allé voter pour ces femmes le
montrer ses cheveux après 20 ans c'est
comme si je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
je pose dans l'eure dans leur peau
visiblement métier je me dis il ya il ya
quelque chose qui va au delà de cette
page et religieux qui sonne juste parce
que ça laisse rien mais une impression
mais je rends l'impression que la
majorité des gens qui portent le voile
sur tous mes temps au québec
ils font part
appartenance à leur culture par un
parent plutôt que par vraiment
convictions religieuses dans
l'impression et le cse comme tu dis
cassis grandit on s'attache le thé au
quartier dans quelconque grandi aux gens
qui sont culturelles encore le temps des
dents des causses une personne serait
forcé de faire quoi que ce soit avait le
souci c'est pas correct le tri non c'est
ça puis en même temps
nous on juge que ces personnes ne sont
forcés de porter quelque chose avec
notre garde occidentaux mais moi je
forçais de faire des affaires je m'en
rends pas compte parce que je chante les
trolls c'est tellement ancré dans ma
culture que je la questionne pas pareil
comme on mange la des animaux sains tout
en dénonçant la cruauté envers les chats
et les chiens on réalise pas que cela
mais ma famille mais je n'oublie pas ce
que j'allais
quand tu t'habitues à quelque chose ça
vient ça vient à toi puis c'est plus
nécessairement à ce titre m religieux
politique exactement mais un autre
élément aussi c'est que même s'il ya des
femmes qui sont forcés vraiment à portée
de voix que jean sinon leur magie les
bords blancs drake j'ai du sang min
besoin à choisir de quel jeu ouais mais
maintenant que des femmes qui
effectivement vivent une obligation de
porter le voile
est-ce que ça va vraiment les aider de
leur interdire l'accès à des postes
un travail qui le travaillent
généralement un vecteur d'émancipation
sociale d'intégration est ce que ces
femmes là on va les aider en les
cantonnant dans des écoles privées
islamique
est-ce qu'on va vraiment leur rendre
service bi déjà cette idée là de sauver
les femmes c'est très instrumentaliser
un comme étant une position féminisme
pour de vrai c'est très c'est très
paternaliste saharienne féministe à mon
avis je trouve que c'est pas je sais que
des féministes pour qui le voile est
vraiment un symbole d'oppression à
combattre mais je trouve que de prendre
pour acquis que des femmes sont pas
capables de prendre des décisions pour
elle même si c'est loin d'être féministe
fêterait infantilisant motivé stade est
beau
ce que j'attends j'ai caché aux quinze
mecs je manquerais simple hockey dont
elle tant mieux mais non mais parce que
c'est vrai que c'est pas et porte un nom
c'est simple on fait comme si c'était
notamment une énorme de au québec oui si
on sent christophe mantoux et on parle
pas anglais
je me crispe à des victimes ce projet
trop niais qui en ce moment mais je
trouve que c'est tellement pas le plus
il n'y a pas d'enjeu là pour moi en ce
moment autour des gens qui portent le
voile il ya un enjeu envers il ya des
enjeux environnementaux qu'ils sont
bêtes plus urgentes dont le voile en ce
moment l'oeil des inondations il ya des
gens qui s'occupent des victimes de ceux
qui ont si c'est à cause de nous qui ont
auront fait pas un plus une mais ceci
c'est une technique pas politique
vieille comme le monde édition détourner
le regard
il ya un problème moi michaud m
tantôt on parlait on change un peu de
sujet de tu parlais de quentin carnaille
coach quand tu prends la parole dans une
cause les gens te voient un peu comme
sur sur un piédestal morale l'exigent
avec une exception exactitude salles en
mai
quand tu es sur cette espèce de quand
les personnes tout vois ta position
comme supérieure à la leur sans faute à
qui démarre ce mois j'ai remarqué un
réflexe direct de vouloir trouver une
feuille automatiquement dans n'importe
quel autre sphère
ouais d'être de temps de t'arrêter dit
oui puis ce j'imagine que tout doit le
vivre constamment du monde j'essaie de
trouver en rayon pour la cause des
femmes en mai de la fin puis gentil
féminisme et tout bas qui est méchant
ben moi et mes tantes et viggen mais tv
gagnent tous dit que c'est bon pour
l'environnement mais tu prends l'avion
oui c'est mieux pour l'environnement
mais en même temps qu'il vit en moi je
trouve ça extrêmement difficile à
soutenir
ça me mènera à la question eux que je
voulais être posée par rapport à
l'activisme durable comment tu fais pour
perdurer dans le temps parce que un des
activistes de gamme qui était le plus
qu'aider le plus central gary offs qui
juste pris sa retraite jeunes de
l'activiste parce que lui c'était y
était plus capable de gérer cette espèce
de
de toujours devoir se justifier pour
tous ces comportements parce qu'il
prenait position pour une cause précise
comment tu vois surtout à ce qu'est ce
que c'est
est-ce que ça ça tu es tour disent que
ça s'essouffle est ce que ça te puise
mais moi j'ai pris mais j'ai pris une
pause de ma chronique au journal métro
ya deux ans un jeteur brno j'étais
vraiment épuisée je t'ai je me sentais
incomprise
puis je trouvais bon y avait toutes
sortes d'éléments là bas mais pis je
suis revenu deux ans plus tard avec une
autre attitude une autre perspective qui
il ya quelqu'un qui m'a fait comprendre
la différence entre la colère et
l'indignation
moi ça m'a aidé la colère c'est une
indignation très très très violente que
tu retournes comme toi puis
l'indignation c'est la capacité de
trouver qu'il ya des injustices qu'ils
sont
on peut d'ailleurs moi j'étais en colère
j'étais vraiment dans la colère j'étais
affecté par les injustices amenait me
mini mon moral ramener ça venait
sarlande mm
c'est un poison c'est la colère puis
j'ai transformé ça je pense qu'on a un
je pense que ça me donne chercher pour
des réseaux qui m'appartiennent que j'ai
réglé avec la psychothérapie mais si ça
m'a permis d'avoir une perspective
nouvelle
sur ces injustices le de livres voire de
les constater ça qui est bien de
m'atteindre personnellement mais je
pense que ça répond à ta question parce
que toute la question
donc moi ça me permet d'aborder les
enjeux sociaux de cette manière est
peut-être un peu plus détaché ce sens à
des tâches est totalement dans ce sens
que je continue à les voir je continue à
aller dénoncer tant tout me demander si
je pouvais écouter occupation soit à
tourner sans tomber même ma grille
d'analysé robinet c'est ma réponse fut
non mais j'ai quand même eu beaucoup de
plaisir à regarder le tout les épisodes
de passer six ans paul ii sans avoir
besoin d'écrire sur chaque exactions
exactement qui met quant à elle cette
réalité là où on se fait prêter nos
failles ce que je réalise de plus en
plus c'est étant donné qu' il ya des
gens qui me confère une autorité en
matière de féminisme ou de droits lgbt
des fois vont se sentir pas à l'aise
avec moi 2
d'aborder certains enjeux ou de parler
de certaines choses ou ben moi aussi
même ça va m'arriver par exemple avec
des militants antiracistes d'avoir pas
d'être inadéquate ou des gels vie mais
aussi fait que je comprends c'est quoi
d'abord peur de faire des faux pas ou
deux mais je pense que à partir du
moment où
on reconnaît que c'est une possibilité
on n'est pas parfait on a le droit
d'être un parfait c'est totalement
légitime ça se peut que je sois
maladroite pour aborder des enjeux qui
me concerne pas personnellement même
pour aborder des enjeux qui me concerne
personnellement mais que j'ai pas été
actualisé de la même façon que toi à
partir du moment où je reconnais qu'on
ne le droit d'être parfait je pense que
ça ça allège un peu le le start on doit
absolument qu'ils mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile à être portés toujours
ses causes là ça vient avec un regard
sur nous ça vient avec des gens qui
effectivement temps de nous discréditer
de toutes les façons possibles et qu'ils
décèlent nos contradictions pour lui
pour invalider nous pas surpris
[Musique]
c'est ça concrètement dans au jour le
jour de changer des choses dans
ce que c'était pour sa santé mentale
dans les deux dernières années ça a été
vraiment un processus mais dont la place
que les réseaux sociaux occupent dans
nos vies on commence à mesurer le fait
que ça a un impact sur notre santé
mentale
non j'ai pris une distance par rapport
aux réseaux sociaux n'est une façon d'y
arriver
j'ai commencé à lire des romans etc en
btcc on passe notre journée devant des
écrans
quand je passe une heure à lire vraiment
j'ai l'impression d'être allé ailleurs
ce sera un exemple j'ai toujours été
super actif accès de la course pidio
gars tu sais que l'espace la crise des
endorphines qui permet d'amasser j'ai
besoin j'imagine qu'en quittant la
compétition tu le ressens mais un petit
il fallu que je me trouve des objectifs
pour incapable de motiver parce que
c'est comme ça que je fonctionne sur que
d'être capable de jouer mais aof pendant
deux heures
mon cerveau je reviens chez nous pu plus
ou moins fatigué qu'avant d'être allé
ouais c'est la charge mentale vraiment
de ce je croyais pas que s'arrête comme
ce tir je croyais pas que met-on prendre
position cela demande solide le devenir
une espèce de devoir vit constamment est
en interaction avec lions une autre
chose que j ai changé par rapport
justement être en interaction avec les
gens c'est de faire plus de place à
l'empathie
quand les gens et sont pas d'accord avec
moi sur les réseaux sociaux puis bon
mais manifester d'une manière parfois
agressive j'essaie d'avoir d'empathie
pour piles me dire sept personnes
souffrent pourquoi pas chez quelqu'un de
manière agressive
s'il n'y a pas une part de souffrance je
pense la personne de soufre qui ces
souffrances va va identifier mettons que
ses souffrances sont à cause des
féministes ou à cause des femmes où est
mon temps que si c'est pas les bonnes
y'a pas identifier les bonnes lubango
cause est bonne source à sa souffrance
mais sa souffrance elle est légitime de
comprendre ça me permet d'avoir plus
d'empathie envers cette personne n'a
envie de lui répondre parce que
l'agressivité
sucette l'agressivité moi je réponds
sans être agressif je désamorce
rapidement l'association
maintenant je peux pas être la
travailleuse sociale du web répondent
avec un passage à tout le monde mais des
fois je le fais pousser ses ressources
glyn berry une catharsis pour toi ben
ouais et une autre un autre et chose que
je fais qui a changé c'est des bons avec
les réseaux sociaux on compte beaucoup
là dessus bord notre vie sociale puis
surtout dans le domaine des idées
réalisé qu'il y avait un grand bénéfice
à rencontrer les gens aux personnes puis
vous le vous le faites avec votre
podcast mais je pense que c'est super
simple aiba nuancé beaucoup de points
communs que des opinions divergent
ça nous permet d'être réellement relier
ce que vraiment les réseaux sociaux nous
donne une illusion d'être lié alors
qu'on lit vraiment pas gd chose comme ça
que j'ai mis en place mais très il ya
des éléments la dengue sont très
concrets ce qu'ils sont fermes les
réseaux sociaux partir d'une tu n'en
fais pas de jets pas d'eric vous prépare
à ça par contre quand tu es quand j'ai
quitté ma chronique au journal métro
pendant comme deux mois j'ai pas été sur
les réseaux sociaux j'ai rien publier
presque
qui sait ça comme fait une zone tampon
puis j'ai pu jamais eu la même attitude
par rapport aux réseaux sociaux
naturellement type je pense que j'ai
cassé une habitude point où j'ai
justement tease et je ressens pas le
besoin de médine et sur tout les
éléments et ben il ya deux ans je te
réponds ça comme une dépendance qu'une
façade rage petite rencontre qu'il était
dépendant pour voir si ce n'est un exam
et italie deux semaines au pérou dans
les montagnes n'est pas de pot
d'internet oui je te rends compte en
maudit à quel point celui d'avoir
internet le temps 03/06 l'impression de
redevenir un humain droit d'avoir des
idées tout a vraiment l'impression je
salue sa flotte était sur la suite
pendant deux mois ça m'a vraiment fait
réaliser à quel point est il j'ai faut
le positif les réseaux sociaux j'aurai
toujours à regarder d'abord il faudra
bien utiliser puis à peu devenir fixé
parce que ça en foule et y ait de plus
en plus d'études étudié plus de priorité
je pense qu'on commence à voir que les
réseaux sociaux agissent un peu comme
une dépendance et like le sas écrite ne
fait sécréter de l'âge que j'avais juste
coupable de pas avoir lieu au puy magie
n'est effectivement l'aller ça envoie
pas envisager les systèmes de
récompenses pis et quand honda comme je
pense que ça a joué dans les mêmes temps
de cerveau pis effectivement c'est ce
faucon faucon ce genre instagram ont une
drôle d'idée
puis ils ont enlevé probablement parce
qu'ils ont remarqué que c'était une
drôle d'idée
à chaque fin de la semaine d'envoyer un
[Musique]
notification avec le temps que tu as
passé le téléphone
instagram qu'il faisait moi j'ai reçu la
première notification
j'ai paniqué en position ma vie au
complet représentants des deux camps les
fêtes j'ai laissé mon seul dans ma poche
quand je suis revenue ce temps les
failles d'évoquer
voici comment je fonctionne à bartenheim
parce que juste cette notification
l'homme effrayer le tank puis quel
pourcentage du temps que j'étais là
dessus est ce que je t'ai vraiment en
train de faire quelque chose et c'était
vraiment engage engagé à faire de quoi
de connaître deux premiers temps on
passe à être juste avant tout la même
photo parce que quand on on n'est plus
capable d'attendre capable ma mère me
disait toujours à ross show à rejeter
toujours pour avoir un livre avec toi et
étudient à la fac elle me pousse à
attendre mais là on a le téléphone piste
allemande a maté productif le site ici
ce que j'essaie de mais c'est aussi de
prendre connaissance de son de remplacer
ça des fois dix âgés jusqu'à 10 minutes
à tuer
même le nombre de choses que tu peux
faire en dix minutes qui sont plus haute
que jack et des photos sur instagram
c'est beaucoup de choses c'est comme un
combat comme tout le temps sera plaidé
jacques est le bienvenu de la gare c'est
comme est accro à poudre mais tout à
voir une petite hache en tapotant
complètement ses portes à lille
[Rires]
pis le je fais juste de lancer des trucs
parce que je veux avant tout en appuyant
sur certaines affaires par rapport aux
vagues à nice mme
une fois que tu prends connaissance du
concept du spécisme oui
pictures tu le trouve légitime fait que
tu peux tu peux tu peux savoir c'est
quoi donc de considérer des espèces
différentes d'autres espèces mais si tu
le juge légitime que moi c'est mon
copain les humains on est une espèce
animale comme le cochon ouais faut que
tu juges sont légitimes
un peu vive en sachant ce qui se passe
moi c'est ça ma question parce que je me
force moi-même à dire
c'est pas si grave que ça parce que
sinon sinon tu peux pas vivre dans ce
monde là vivent dans un monde où tout
est père sont des criminels
exact c'est ce que j'en avais parlé à
élise sony killzone excuse moi excuse
moi et bisous nicky et qui dresse une
sommité vegan exactement min tang vegan
puis accepter ce qu'on veut semblable
sont dans la même position
les personnes pro vie on l'a dans le
sang sont contre l'avortement il
considère que ceux qui ont eu des
avortements s'est dit je ne sais pas
comment on arrive à réconcilier sur moi
personnellement j'adhère à la taille je
continue à consommer des produits
animaux qui dit comment est ce que tu
m'as jamais ce que tu penses c'est ça ma
question c'est parce que mais je pense
que c'est très culturelle c'est
tellement je pense que c'est beaucoup
plus ancré dans notre culture de
consommer ccc s'est produit le sens
questionner si on a donné des noms
différents attendront dis pas qu'on
mange du cochon
comment le sport et puis c'est juste un
exemple y ont toute petite bécane
week-end pour l'autre
le nom qui est fait
je pense qu'il faut plutôt faire le
chemin inverse est beaucoup plus
difficile de se rappeler à chaque fois
qu'on mange de la viande ou des produits
animaux que on mange quelque chose qui
fait souffrir le gothique
j'en ai pas de justification pour un pot
de pavillons c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
qui me plaît je me réconforte dans l'ide
dans l'oubli non non dans le fait de
faire du déni source et sur cette puce
pense que c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est si c'est la vente comme idéologie
parce que le compromis se fait comme moi
et des gens qui sauf même and by que je
pense que le compromis est trop gros en
ce moment pour culturellement pour la
plupart des gens pas que les gens
préfèrent de loin est dans le déni nom
exact exact puis gilles un livre
naissant des premiers essais sur le
véganisme que j'ai lus en sorte en
occupation double qui s'appelait comment
voir mon style comme un animal man way
we dance etc
à défaut d'être vegan tout le monde
devrait prôner le véganisme plus de ce
sombre mais c'est vraiment ma posture
est avec vous les gueules mais chut chut
c'est sûr que je mange vraiment moins de
produits animaux que la plupart des jeux
que l'on ne jette rien à blonde est
végétarienne à la maison on mange bien
et à rien et puis je peux je capote pour
sa viande qui met
mais c'est ça il sait déjà les fêtes le
défi 21 jours vivendi ça me priver de
lait et de fromages et 2 c'était les
choses les plus difficiles
je n'ai pas rendu le séjour qui s'est
encore passé mais en même temps au moins
trois soupes et par semaine on sait
begin puis on s'en rend pas compte
dès qu'on mange des repas avec du tofu
avec des protéines végétales la peau du
temps c'est ici mais c'est quand on
essaie d'être agité des protéines dans
leur époque mais ouais je pense
qu'effectivement il faut à défaut de
pouvoir faire ces compromis le
nous-mêmes je pense qu'il faut
reconnaître que c'est totalement
légitime ici c'est vous qui avez raison
payent plus que les ibères c'est juste
qu'on ne ça nous c'est trop cher trop
compromettants c'est j'ai l'impression
dans ce que le même si ce que je vais
dire le
c'est pas tous les activistes vegan qui
dirait ça parce que pour certains
l'urgence est trop
est trop forte c'est de dire pour que
s'arrête maintenant mais ça change une
fois que tu sais que s'arrêtera pas
maintenant aussi du pénible ça peut être
de considérer que ça va continuer encore
pendant des dizaines d'années de se dire
c'est tout le monde prône comme comme
toi comme ton approche comme doom qui
végétarien de dire c'est la chose faut
sans arrêt et louis diminuons notre
consommation de produits d'origine
animale quand tout le monde va se rendre
compte que c'est diminuer
il va avoir des trucs qui vont remplacer
le lait comme on le connaît le lait de
vache comme on le connaît
ou alors des trucs qui vont là c'est
qu'ils savent déjà qu'ils seraient déjà
ces peoples lll et à iew clients qu'ils
allaient bien rédigé maintenant des
affaires comme ce chalet dans une scène
si l'on fait semaine au salon du livre
la côte nord il y avait une cafétéria
que tout le temps une option vg et puis
c'est ça qui me disait en fait la liste
des oignons faisait étant donné que
tellement de mes affaires je préfère me
réjouir des améliorations c'est laurent
c'est justement sur ce sol pour la est
fâché contre les lecteurs à des repos
qui s'est beaucoup plus premièrement
constructif pied je pense qu'on va y
arriver je pense que mettons nos
générations
je regarde les gens qui ont des enfants
autour de moi c'est maintenant que ton
enfant de n1m pas la viande de ce qu'il
connaît beaucoup d'impôts tuent le fort
recul le plus fort depuis maintenant si
cette personne va grandir dans un
environnement où mais ne te fup il est
super cool type c'est ce que je préfère
c'est pâques qui je pense que les
générations futures vont de plus en plus
avoir un regard ixic par rapport à notre
consommation de produits animaux qui ça
va changer je pense que ça va et on va y
parvenir de cette façon le mais je
comprends que pour les générations qui
précède est jamais inclus là bas c'est
des compromis qui sont encore celles à
faire comprendre c'est avec avec toi là
dedans tu seppi je comprends vraiment la
posture vegan day si pour toi maintenant
manger de la viande c'est comparable à
leurs troupes à wad l'esclave âge que
provenant de wall ag juste deux esclaves
comptera vraiment imaginer ce qu'on
attend c'est quand même qu'on abolisse
lavage ou là vous avez eu le droit à
deux jours par semaine et esclavage
c'est difficile pour lui parce que
l'idée pis la théorie de tout et comme
noble mais sans être pragmatique il faut
être dans la régie
si je fais du bénévolat à tous les
jeudis dans un lieu d'hébergement pour
femmes en situation d'itinérance pis il
y a les menus sont pas obligés tard et
puis même si c'est difficile pour
quelqu'un qui gagnent vraiment de
trouver son compte le soir ses piges
comme
imagine qu'un jour ce genre
d'organisation l'oeuvre avant
essentiellement des menus végétariens
beaucoup de femmes parmi les
bénéficiaires de l'auberge qui sont
végétariennes ville mais en ce moment
est ce que tu veux et posée qui pour moi
c'est pas quelque chose qui combine
poserait pour moi un rêve si quelqu'un
prépare et amoureux mais tous mes repas
je lui dirais de me préparer juste dire
pauvre gundy si c'était pas compliqué
mais quelqu'un qui vit dans la rue qui
vit vraiment plusieurs pressions qui est
vraiment au bas de l'échelle du postulat
forcer à manger quelque chose qui avec
laquelle est pas famille artistique et
des femmes d'un certain âge pour elle le
tofu c'est rébarbatif l'utiliser c'est
pas il ya en tout des petits souvent
s'est basé sur des conceptions des
pastous à 10 ans français des idées
préconçues qu'elle te fuis c'est bof
c'est pas bon ça coûte rien mais tu es
je pense si on est dans une période de
transition où des institutions devraient
comme offrir une option végétarienne
tout le temps puis à mener il va y avoir
des repas végétariens qui de moins en
moins d'options avec des produits
animaux au big c mais je pense que les
réflexions qui peuvent pas être simple
comme juste exode des criminels
je sais pas ce que je pense que s'ils
s'y mettant sa femme il t'avait gagnent
des critiques parce que cette position
là je trouve ça dommage parce que pour
le reste c'est celle que puis c'est le
cas aussi justement jean philippe il
seuil il ya là même si j'applique qui
prend le mal est la figure vigueur au
québec
georges là avec la avec le plus de
capital de sympathie au mieux
ils 8 c
tu as ta grand-mère de fait des biscuits
avec des oeufs
tu peux goûter ses biscuits pis c'est
fait c'est peut être amorcé par la
commode par les activistes
il est adoré par les gens comme moi
ouais ils sont qui sont plus nuancés ma
blonde aussi à la gorge en flex a
rétorqué que c'est l'âme même que nous
par contre y en a qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec ça sa présence était
puisque rated ce qu'avec des prêtres
d'accord c'est jusque
au lieu de se dire on n'est pas
parfaitement d'accord mais on a la même
cause puis on venait à la même direction
des fois ça vire en attaque puisque ça
fait juste comme ça
en général c'est que tu en a certains
qui ont différentes visions maintenant
de féministes que toi puis le sas care
lp des footeux point de vue passe à la
droite et crampons parce que tu es
cannibalise entre elles mais je me
réjouis en me disant qu'est la droite ou
si ces ondes de jeunes qui comme moi
justement quand tu te dis des gros oui
quittait font passer pour un gros con
lyon se eux aussi mais ouais
souvent c'est qu'on ait tout le monde
vit dans le même panier puis à des gens
qui pensent que tu es comme jean paul i
speak étaient plus nuancées hippiques
mais certaines personnes plus j'veux pas
caricaturer mais il ya certaines
personnes ou ce que ça devient parfois
un concours de la vertu le tout le monde
qui est un petit peu moins de vertus que
toi sarko dit des fois c'est très vite
au rythme qui sait qu'ils maîtrisent le
mieux les codes puis il ya une espèce de
plaisir à montrer qu'il maîtrise les
codes mais je devrais je pense pas que
ce soit la majorité puis je comprends la
tentation parce que tu as envie
d'appliquer une grille d'analysé qui de
l'appliquer jusqu'au bout bien mauvais
temps le toit il faut aussi aimer ton
ses idées le khimki souvent se propage
amis universitaires sac red bull veut
veut pas le type il est tellement de sa
crainte c'est qu'on concède klopp l'état
prend des nouveaux concepts fac
ces petites étaient plus portés à les
voir là tu sais pas ce que c'est si
nouveau soft est excité par ce qui est
engagé par ce souk est très solide il
faut s'y rendre ce caractère pragmatique
pis comment appliquer ce qu'on va faire
passer ce message là vraiment toi tu
sais le mot pragmatique le souvent les
radicaux il ya le feu parce que c'est
comme pragmatique c'est comme une façon
faire des compromis c'est comme ça que
j'essaie d'être gentil mais
ses commentaires plus influent sur la
question semble forte c'est que ça prend
de tout ça en prend des radicaux qui bon
mais je pense que willis que le miel
c'est aussi problématique que le
croupier
je pense que ça prend des radicaux pour
réfléchir à la passerelle radical s'est
dit souhaiter aller à la racine du
problème
ces emprunts qui ça prend des gens qui
permettent une meilleure adhésion de
plus large à la cause parce qu'aux gens
qui aiment et pour tout le monde
s'écoute dans cette direction commune
logement mais effectivement je suis
d'accord que tu l'aies les activistes
je déteste le mot extrémistes mais les
activistes plus sur le plancher unis qui
doit peut-être radical qui
qui font voir d'aidé
des choses qu'on verrait pas sinon par
exemple du monde qui vont de covenants
des dents des des abattoirs qui vont
être heureux dans des fermes de fourrure
qui sort des vidéos de l'ops oms
sont dégueulasses chose que moi je ferai
jamais jamais de la vie je pense à
prendre
oui oui c'est l'humain au chaud si je ne
serai pas viguen aujourd'hui si elle est
pas des gens vraiment extrême qui
l'avait précédé étaient les gens qui ont
un qui ont commencé à être vigilent
s'était dirigé les extrémistes et les
intelligents qui même les végétariens a
commencé ce pays
voyons donc il va pas manger de viande
série comme il faut toujours remettre en
perspective que les idées qu'on trouve
extrêmement aujourd'hui souvent mais ils
sont saisis ils seront plus grand pub
actuellement il y en a que 8 6 jeudi
des phénomènes avec lesquels on sera
jamais à rise avec raison métier il faut
sera appliquée dans le temps que les
femmes militaires pour le droit de vote
ont ri et dell oui on va les trouver un
trajet l'extrémisme oui
ouais
son regard des cours d'histoire ça ça va
pas par le sang va parler exactement ne
sait jamais si le convertit
conservatisme
je pense que des fois certains
conservateurs le bus est juste de dire
on va on va mettre le pied sur le frein
pour trans youn et d'une manière très
souvent c'est des gens qui sont attachés
à un ordre établi pas et puis
généralement j'aurais tendance à dire
parce que ça les favorites
il ya un intérêt ou si c'est pas
désintéressée pas nécessairement pour le
bien commun nécessairement mais pis ces
corps et c'est correct et des
conservateurs sur le rebord découverte
nous autour de bordeaux cub et repique
et apprend de tout pour faire un bon il
y avait une question que je vais
demander si c'est tantôt justement on
parlait de t&d fois l'ailier la gauche
risque alors d'entrer au travail ou qui
vont personnalité votre quelque chose à
tout le monde en parle dimanche que
lundi ça va être on va répondre ce qui
dans certains cas
andreck a pas de rédemption possible
pour une personne qui se sent ça
tim est encore qu on prend l'exemple de
kevin rudd aux etats unis si l'humoriste
nos actes insensés admise au sporting
qui a fait du tout il ya plusieurs
couches la donne
c'est vers lui parce qu'il est noir que
dans une maurice qui ont peut-être fait
des jo comme homophobe qui tous les
jours qu'ils sont des drames aux faibles
encore parfois son drôle c'est donc le
dans ce sens mais parfois c'est pas
nécessairement la réelle pas si vous
êtes en perspective pied mais c'est
simpliste et mettons quelqu'un qui met
généralement c'est déjà très dense que
le sont pas homophobes
bon ça se dit john deleus sexuelles
pendant six mois mais
en plus ces âmes est un humoriste qui
fait premièrement
qu'un style très consensuel ne saisit
pas un polémiste ou cpo quelqu'un qui a
un style d'humour rama qui va jouer sa
ligne ce qui fait qu'ils avaient des
twists exactement dit jack à caractère
homophobe qui passe il ya eu 10 ans
étant le contexte d'écroulement pas tout
le monde aujourd'hui mais oui exactement
dans ce code qui lui même a constamment
faisait tout le monde regarde ces jo
club adapté au monde uc c est le après
ceux déjà trop ceux
reinhardt et des blagues homophobes qui
ça devient une grosse affaire fine
parfait kolélas au tpi et s'excuse si je
ne suis pas cette personne là où j'ai
évolué ou si je pensais que c'était
drôle c'est l'époque qui on avance mais
on continue puis si j'ai heurté des gens
sincèrement je m'excuse pas que ça
continue
- 7 avril serait que ça m'est arrivé
j'ai tenu des positions par exemple sur
le blackface il ya plusieurs années que
j'entends ce plu du tout il ya un mois
vraiment fait qu'on prend une bonne
façon c'est que on m'a fait comprendre
pourquoi c'était une pratique qui était
inadéquate qu'il ya des gens qui m'en
veulent encore piqué m'en tienne rigueur
encore et je peux comprendre cela cela
dit je te dirais que c'est vraiment une
minorité de personnes a précisé que
les autorités qui avaient donné qu'ils
avaient confié ce mandat la haca bonheur
qui lui ont retiré
moi à partir du moment où quelqu'un
reconnaît ses torts puis s'excuse je
trouve que ces différents contextes sont
pas un crime et les niveaux de violence
mais moi à moi je serais plutôt d'avis
cela dit j'ai posté j'ai pas suivi
complètement folle et mes clubs je sais
pas est ce que ces excuses étaient
réellement sincère c'est souvent les
gens vont dire je m'excuse si mes propos
ont pu offenser certaines personnes
passent on n'a pas su mais vraiment
c'est en s'excusant il l'expert la
perception de l'autre
il explique surtout horgen quelqu'un
d'aller qui disait que quand c'est sorti
tout cela il ya dit je m'excuse
puis je voulais pas dire sage plusieurs
personnes ne puis après ça je pense que
ce qui était problématique avec la
communauté lgbt q c'est que heu
il voulait pas répéter encore ses
excuses a voulu qu'ils aillent sur
toutes les plateformes section surtout
je me suis excusé répétaient quelquefois
jusqu'à dans qui est à chaque fois
qu'ils s'excusent saper le damany d'en
parler on dirait que pour certaines
personnes c'est comme il peut pour venir
parler c'est tout toi tu es morte et
même ce faisant un salut mais pour
combien de personnes c'est
il ya peut-être deux personnes qui
continuent à en tenir rigueur
ça change pas ma façon de vivre piquer
sa chaussure plate mais j'aimerais ça
parlait avec ces personnes on one pour
la france si tu mais si tu avais encore
cette idée le petit défendant quand ta
position mais il ya encore matière à
critiquer mais péter je pense que ce
soit rayée de toutes les listes à vie
pour son animation puis certaines qui
aura d'autres occasions mais après ça
des cas des décideurs prennent des
décisions en fonction d'une grogne
populaire qui peut-être minoritaires les
apaches pense que les oscars c'est c'est
tellement politically correct qui
voulait éviter toute forme de
controverses puis on peut penser à
pleurer pour la wii wheel voir que c'est
juste c'est quand même une injustice
envers lui je pense même si on se dit ça
va bien aller pour lui oui
non je comprends si longtemps avec vous
et d'avoir le temps détaillé sa pensée
le but de ces des choses les gens
feraient qui lis ton livre qui allait
militantisme à l'ère des réseaux sociaux
ou encore wii dans le métro piste pour
l'instant je suis comme vraiment
contente de l'est de la vitrine que sa
bible haute c'est vraiment les idées que
je voulais mettre de l'avant sur
lesquels j'ai planché pendant deux ans
puis je ça m'a vraiment fait du bien de
prendre l'espace nécessaire pour
expliquer ma pensée puis pour l'instant
je voudrais que les gens lisent moins la
presse aurait d'autres projets à propos
cool cool merci pour le plaisir
[Musique]